bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d' europe hebdo nous sommes à
strasbourg au coeur du parlement
européen et dans cette émission zoom sur
les ogm avec un reportage en espagne
premier producteur en europe
d'organismes génétiquement modifiés
nous verrons que la colère monte dans le
pays mais d'abord l'actualité comment
relancer la croissance dans la zone euro
nous allons poser cette question à
l'invité exceptionnel
martin schulz président du parlement
européen
à peine investi et déjà armé de son
bâton de maréchal de berlin à washington
françois hollande a un objectif la sacro
sainte croissance
pour ce faire il devra convaincre ses
homologues de la nécessité d'une relance
allié de poids
barack obama mariano rajoy mario monti
mais angela merkel elle n'en démord pas
son credo pas d'eurobonds la bonne tenue
des finances publiques et la rigueur la
rigueur et encore la rigueur
pas si simple après lac ce mercredi
voilà qu'on raille le maire claude un
couple qui pour l'instant ne vit pas
vraiment de lune de miel les prévisions
sont mauvaises
zéro croissance en zone euro cette année
et le climat social est plus que tendue
la grèce s'enfonce dans la crise
politique et aujourd'hui on parle sans
ambages de sa prochaine sortie de
l'europe l'italie le portugal croule
sous les déficits
en espagne c'est la santé des banques
qui inquiète le taux de chômage y
atteint des cimes et l'émigration des
espagnols vers d'autres eldorado a
repris alors qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
la croissance
martin schultz merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes président de ce parlement
depuis quelques mois on a vu depuis ces
derniers temps il ya quand même la crise
de la zone euro est à son comble on a
l'impression que c'est encore une une
redite ça fait quand même trois ans que
cette crise dure en gala merkel refuse
toujours les eurobonds les project bonds
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire selon
vous pour réussir à infléchir sa
position envers âge je ne suis pas sûr
que ça va tenir très longtemps après les
élections en france et l'arrivée
transforme à l'arrivée de françois
hollande à l'elysée il est logique que
l'âge honda en europe change
je suis que quelques temps en temps je
surpris sur le débat public parce que
les gens me posent par exemple la
question est est ce que vous croyez que
quelque chose va changer et si la
deuxième nation membre de l'union
européenne la france remplace un
président sortant conservateur par un
président ce cette liste logiquement la
politique change tant que je crois les
eurobonds et les questions de la
croissance de la lutte ciblées contre le
chômage surtout des jeunes
aussi la revue que les chiffres étaient
très mauvais ex
j'étais en grèce était en espagne c'est
terrible c'est même menace pour la
démocratie
donc il faut qu'on mettre ces choses sur
l'agenda et j'en suis sûre que
il y aura un changement dans la
stratégie de l'union européenne et des
états membres de l'union europe on parle
aujourd'hui de robot est effectivement
gala merkel ne veut pas vous allez voter
enfin vous avez mis en place hier avec
le tri noble dont commission conseil
parlement européen la possibilité
d'émettre dans des débuts de project
bonds donc cesser ses possibilités en
fait d'emprunter ensemble pour financer
des grands projets c'était un projet qui
était porté par jacques delors des 90
nous sommes en 2011 il a fallu 20 ans
pour arriver à ce résultat ça a été voté
mardi donc 22
est-ce qu'il faudra encore 20 ans
aujourd'hui pour mettre en place les
eurobonds c'est une question qu'il faut
poser pas au président du parlement
européen nous sommes près de faire
n'importe quel de prendre n'importe
quelle mesure pour l'appliquer mais le
sénat en france par exemple on pourrait
facilement poser la question au
gouvernement précédentes surtout
pourquoi la france n'a pas pris
l'initiative l'europe à une large
majorité des gouvernements qui sont
hésitants donc c'est pas le parlement
nous sommes pour depuis très longtemps
nous avons soutenu dès lors il y a vingt
ans pour cela s'est pas échoué à cause
des institutions européennes c'est à
cause des états membres pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils la bce la banque centrale
européenne n'est pas le prêteur en
dernier ressort
parce que c'est pour le moment pas
publiées mais il était déjà le cas le
moment où le banque centrale européen
c'est comme le rebond on ne dit pas ce
qui se passe ils ont acheté mais votre
question mène dans une autre direction
si c'est nécessaire il faut ça c'est ma
réponse si c'est nécessaire il faut que
la banque centrale européen a agi comme
les mauves la cerise autres comme le fed
aux états unis vous le souhaitez vous
qui êtes allemand est ce que si vous
aviez un gala marquera en face de vous
je lui diriez il faut je cite angela
merkel dans un discours au forum du
süddeutsche zeitung il ya six mois je
suis contre mais je respecte la pleine
indépendance de la banque centrale
européenne à bill martin schulz autre
sujet qui préoccupe nos voisins
européens c'est le sort de la grèce
sortira-t-elle ou pas de la zone euro
c'est la question qui m
les médias cette semaine petit tour des
télévisions étrangères avec aurélie
d'afas sortir on ne sortira pas pour le
premier ministre britannique david
cameron le choix des grecs très être
clair et il doit s'exprimer aux
prochaines élections mais devant
maintenant envoyer un message très clair
au peuple grec
c'est un choix vous pouvez soit voté
pour rester dans l'euro en respectant
les engagements qui vont avec
ou si vous votez différemment et bien
vous quittez les zones à la possible
sortie de l'euro n'est donc plus un
tabou mais elle reste un épouvantail
elles font frémir ses experts espagnols
ce serait la première phase de la
disparition de l'euro et cette monnaie
est devenue la deuxième réserve la plus
importante au monde
elle a atteint un tel niveau de
confiance qu'on ne peut pas la faire
disparaître la la sortie de la grèce de
l'euro serait une crise profonde à la
fois monétaire et financière mais aussi
politique que c'est la même politique en
grèce les épargnants panique à l'idée
d'une dévaluation monétaire le bnq
ronning devient une sorte de sport
national
courir vers sa vente pour vider ses
comptes cela porte désormais un nom
nathalie le bang running en grèce 700
millions d'euros ont été retirés lundi
passé depuis ces 100 millions par jour
qui sortent des coffres et en espagne on
pratique aussi le bain running on parle
d'un milliard d'euros retirés en moins
d'une semaine
faut-il que la grèce sorte de la zone
euro absolument le contraire et les cas
il faut que nous gardons la grèce des
dons et que nous restons ensemble d un
état membre doit quitter la saône et
rhône états membres de la zone euro doit
le quitter
l'aspiq spéculation contre le prochain
pays comment ça sera les rails alors tu
gueules italie et ça va aboutir à
l'italie en italie c'est un g8 cet état
j'ai vite c'est la troisième force
économique de l'union européenne et
c'est la troisième la plus endettée au
monde
il faut donc il faut être il faut qu'on
fasse attention et qu'on reste prudent
avec ces débats parce qu'il ya des gens
qui le souhaite christine lagarde qui
parle de sortie ordonnée de la zone euro
c'est une erreur je ne sais pas si c'est
possible si lagarde madame lagarde a à
leurs essais pts
comment ça fonctionne elle peut nous le
dire la phrase seul ne suffit pas s'il y
a un sortie ordonnée de la zone euro je
trouve il ne suffit pas de le dire comme
titre il faut expliquer est-ce qu'il est
maîtrisable
est-ce qu'on peut maîtriser les cloud
système bancaire en grèce
est-ce qu'on peut maîtriser les la vague
de la protestation même du désespoir
social qui suit immédiatement à
l'introduction du drame il ya plusieurs
scénarios
mais si madame lagarde nous dit comment
on peut maîtriser un tel développement
de la pauvreté en données de deux tiers
de la population comment on peut lutter
contre l'évasion des grands capitaux cap
capitaux l'évasion fiscale comment on
peut réintroduire les capitales des
super riches grecs qui achètent au
moment donné des grands appartements à
berlin avec l'engin en hauteur avec
l'argent ou les amateurs avec l'argent
qu'il ne soumettent pas la taxation
qu'il n'est pas imposée en grèce' madame
lagarde à la stratégie pour cela je suis
très reconnaissant qu'elle nous parce je
me méfie même des gens qui ont toujours
ses solutions à la vitesse
à la grèce peut sortir en vitesse
est ce que madame lagarde ou les autres
conseillers ou andy experts qui nous
raconte sa ont aussi un plan pour
l'effet domino pour le système bancaire
espagnol pour le système bancaire
italien juste les grandes agences de
notation sur lesquels il faut aussi
discuter sur le rôle ont dégradé 16
banques italien est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui peut me dire quel impact à
une sortie ordonnée entre guillemets
citation enfin de madame lagarde de la
grèce de la zone euro
quel impact cela aura sur le système
bancaire en italie
alors pour acheter la faïence moi je
préfère qu'on essaie de garder la
sommerau ensemble la condition la
condition sinequanone c'est la confiance
mutuelle la grèce a promis des réformes
pour cela les européens et aussi le
fonds monétaire a promis le financement
l'état grec et de la dette souveraine
grecque pour le moment donné si un
nouvel nouveau gouvernement de la grèce
mais sa horde vigueur je peux plus pab
imaginer que l'autre côté continue à
payer c'est ce que quelques parties en
grèce croivent on peut dire on paie plus
mais les autres ne peut pas se permettre
de nous laisser tomber
donc il joue mais là il faut dire et
aussi ils jouent avec le feu comme
saison dira experts le fond aussi donc
je crois la base pour les semaines qui
viennent pour stabiliser leur robe et la
zone euro et qu'on peut compter sur une
expérience très traditionnel tenir
parole
dernière question monsieur schulze
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il faut on a vu
plusieurs sommets de crise
depuis trois ans on doit en être au 13e
est ce qu'il ya un manque de volonté
politique est ce que est ce qu on est
gouverné par des politiques qui savent
où ils vont je crois il n'y a pas de
manque de volonté la structure est faux
nous avons une zone monétaire nous avons
un sommet économique mais nous avons une
fragmentation de la gouvernance nous
avons une zone cohérent économique
monétaire mais nous avons 17
gouvernement et au délà c-17
gouvernement essaie de jouer à la maison
chez eux toujours qu'ils sont eux qui
décident et il marginalise
en même temps avec ça vaut lui au pavot
lui mais il marginalise les institutions
européennes
en ce qui concerne la gouvernance
économique prénom le président sortant
nicolas sarkozy qui j'ai respecté
beaucoup pendant la présidence française
on a travaillé ensemble
vraiment je l'avouer je l' ai avoué
aussi avant les élections comme il
fallait
mais qu'est-ce qu'il dit pendant la
campagne électorale il dit le
gouvernement de l'europe
ces anglais et moi c'est le fameux axe
mercredi pour continuer il dit le
gouvernement de l'europe
j'en ai la moa et trois phrases après il
y met les moyens est mal gouverné
écouter non malbon css et c'est une
blague mais la réalité était que les
gens l'ont pris comme si l'europe
fonctionne c'est le gouvernement
national si l'europe ne fonctionne pas
ce sont des institutions européennes
mais l'union la faute à bruxelles enfin
voilà mais l'union européenne n'est pas
c'est pas l'union européenne qui a créé
la france c'est pas l'union européenne
qui a fondé l'allemagne ou d'écrits
l'existence de l'espagne ce sont les
états membres qui créent qui créé
l'union
l'union européenne est fort ou faible
comme les états membres de l'union
veulent qu'il est fort et faible
donc pour répondre précisément à votre
question nous avons surtout une crise du
système politique
donc c'est un manque de volonté de la
part des gouvernants de laisser un petit
peu de leur souveraineté
ils ont laissé déjà beaucoup de soufre
unités transféré sur le niveau
européenne mais en ce qui concerne la
monnaie est la direction de la sommerau
ils sont pas suffisamment courageux de
renforcer les institutions européennes
merci martin schulz merci à vous avant
de rejoindre kathia gilder et son invité
direction l'espagne le pays d'europe qui
produit le plus d'organismes
génétiquement modifiés mais peu à peu la
contestation s'installent et sebeyran
jardin glace qui nous en parle en ce
moment pour angel c'est l'une des
périodes les plus importantes de l'année
chaque jour il inspecte ses ruches pour
que sa récolte soit la meilleure
possible
des efforts qui pourraient être réduits
à néant
depuis l'automne dernier il a beaucoup
de mal à vendre son miel
comme tout le miel espagnol celui ci est
suspecté de contenir des traces d'eau gm
car en espagne près du quart du maïs
produit du mon810 un maïs génétiquement
modifié or la mémoire est l maïs
aujourd'hui le maïs transgénique en
n'est pas balisé
il a mélangé avec le maïs
conventionnelles et il peut y avoir un
apport de pollen ogm dans la rue sans
que l'apiculture le sache
d'habitude migaud elle vend toute sa
production à l'étranger en allemagne et
en france principalement mais l'an
dernier impossible d'exporter le moindre
pot en cause un jugement de la cour
européenne de justice de septembre 2011
appelés à faire bloc il interdit à la
vente tout miel ou pollen contenant des
ogm et le crémant
à partir du verdict de la cour de
justice personne n'a plus voulu acheter
de miel le marché est resté complètement
bloquée il a fallu attendre pendant
trois mois avant que quelqu'un accepte
d'acheter du miel espagnol y compris le
mien et au moment de l'achat on m'a payé
25 % moins cher que six mois plus tôt
l'espagne est le premier producteur
européen de miel c'est donc l'avenir de
centaines d'apiculteurs qui est en jeu
angel et ses collègues ont décidé de se
battre contre les ogm on février dernier
ils se sont rassemblés à séville la plus
grosse manifestation anti ogm que n'ait
jamais connu la ville à la tête de la
contestation mais wallis cardio élus à
la coag ce syndicat agricole proche de
la confédération paysanne dénonce l'
influence des firmes mondiales sur la
péninsule ibérique
tandis que de nombreux pays européens
renoncent aux organismes génétiquement
modifiés
ici les surfaces ogm continue de
progresser
il essaie de convaincre je pense à
travers l'espagne que la coexistence est
possible alors qu'on sait bien que que
tout ça c'est un gros mensonge
si tu fait déloger m tu d'ailleurs tu es
en train d'interdire que quelqu'un
puisse faire du bio que quelqu'un puisse
faire de l'apiculture on pense que c'est
une stratégie de monsanto et d'autres
entreprises de d'essayer à tout prix de
faire augmenter la surface
pour l'instant le seul ogm autorisé dans
le pays et le maïs mon810 un maïs
contenant un insecticide bt il est
cultivé sur près de cent mille hectares
mais personne ne sait exactement où car
en espagne
il n'existe aucune cartographie des
plantations ogm bac est ici c'est trop
chimique
merci sam n'est pas mais on va pas là
bas c'est sur les bords du guadalquivir
que roanne a décidé de semer du mon 810
comme on le constate le maïs ogm et le
maïs conventionnelles ne sont pas
différencier tous les grains finiront
ensemble pour roanne
pas de quoi s'inquiéter la culture
transgénique sait rien de plus qu un
insecticide
ils n'ont pas changé la graine c'est le
même insecticide bt qu'il réponde par
tonne dans les champs
ça ne vient pas d'un autre monde voilà
trois ans que cet agriculteur ont des
lois a commencé à planter du maïs ogm et
pour lui les rendements sont nettement
meilleures l'an dernier j'ai abandonné
la culture transgénique et la pyrale
larves qui a fait le maïs est apparu
résultat ma production a baissé de 50%
au lieu de 160 170 tonnes par hectare je
n'ai récolté que 80 tonnes géré planter
des ogm car c'est la seule solution
contre la pyrale en espagne si le
pouvoir politique de droite comme de
gauche reste favorable aux ogm
les opposants sont de plus en plus
nombreux ainsi la puebla descazals à une
ville de 11 mille habitants sur la route
de malaga
la commune s'est déclarée sans ogm un
travail de persuasion entrepris par le
maire bendjo a le processus a consisté à
convaincre les agriculteurs de la région
que les produits qui nous arrive en ce
moment et les produits qui sont vendus à
l'international sont contre-productifs
pour le futur de nos enfants ici les
agriculteurs rachète toutes leurs
graines est la coopérative qui garantit
des semences non ogm
pourtant un point bas des cases à la cie
les habitants ont élu un maire écolo
fait encore exceptionnel en espagne les
ogm semble encore bien des bulles pour
la plupart d'entre eux jacques là je ne
sais pas très bien ce que c'est mais je
pense que ce n'est pas bon pour la santé
jara les produits transgéniques sont
modifiées génétiquement par les
multinationales
donc ce n'est pas naturel à mon avis
pendant des années en espagne les ogm
ont été avant tout considéré comme une
avancée scientifique
aujourd'hui certaines associations et
syndicats commencent à mieux informer la
population
agriculteur ou pas ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à vouloir que le pays tout
entier renonce aux cultures
génétiquement modifiées
et pour beaucoup c'est l'avenir de
l'agriculture espagnole qui est en jeu
retour sur le grand plateau de
strasbourg au coeur du parlement
européen nous avons été rejoints par un
député tout juste sortis de l'hémicycle
je vous aiderai bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous députés européens sous
les couleurs ici d'europe écologie et
vous menez depuis des années la lutte
contre les ogm quand vous voyez ce type
de reportage réalisé en espagne et qui
montre l'emprise du mon 810 du nom du
géant américain qui le conçois est ce
que vous vous dites c'est peine perdue
au contraire la lutte continue au
contraire moi je vois ce reportage avec
beaucoup d'encouragements je connais
bien les gens de la cua gh ces
municipalités qui commencent à rentrer
en résistance et il ya un énorme
mouvement en espagne qui est en train de
se développer
l'espagne est le seul pays qui fait des
ogm de manière importante et sur lequel
il n'y a absolument aucun registre comme
ça a été dit donc
l'espagne est une véritable catastrophe
écologique aujourd'hui avec cette
monoculture du maïs qui est une
véritable catastrophe au niveau
environnemental mais aussi au niveau de
la diversité de l'agriculture
donc moi j'ai beaucoup d'espoir qu'en
espagne les choses évoluent
favorablement parce qu'à une pression de
plus en plus forte des citoyens
espagnols
en clair on peut pas dire si telle
partie contient ou pas des ogm parce que
tout ce mélange dans la terre comment
comment ça se passe exactement comment
est-ce que ce type de comment est-ce que
cet apiculteur peut se retrouver avec
ses suspicions de contamination par le
mon810 d'assez simple en espagne a pas
de règle sur la coexistence c'est dire
que l'agriculteur ne doit pas déclaré
n'est pas obligé déclaré n'est pas
obligé de mettre de prendre un certain
nombre de précautions contiennent des
ogm donc tout se fait n'importe comment
n'importe quoi qui fait qu'un apiculteur
ne sais pas quand il va mettre ses
ruches si le maïs qui est en face
contient des ogm ou pas donc ça pose un
problème
un agriculture bio ne sait pas si son
voisin a fait des ogm agricoles
traditionnelles non plus donc celui qui
est par exemple sous label bio
si on analyse son produit qu'on trouve
des ogm dedans il est cassé il a aucun
recours en indemnisation est donc
évidemment c'est une catastrophe sur le
marché local mais aussi quand on voit
exporté dans les autres pays européens
et quelle est la situation en france la
france a pris des clauses une clause de
sauvegarde pour interdire la culture de
ce maïs quelle est la situation est ce
qu on a des garanties de ne pas
retrouver du maïs monsanto 810 dans les
cultures comment ça se passe alors en
france il ya eu un premier moratoire qui
a été mis en place en 2008 qui avait été
attaquée devant la cour européenne de
justice pour des raisons de forme il a
été cassé à nouveau moratoire a été pris
cette année au mois de janvier février
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
un kilo de maïs ogm qui a été semé dans
les champs ce printemps donc aujourd'hui
on est dans une situation où la france
est indemne de maïs mon810 au niveau des
cultures
mais qu'est ce qui nous garantit qu'on
n'a pas de loger est venu d'espagne
c'est un seul grand marché question
qu'est ce qu'un alors au niveau des
semences
un agriculteur aujourd'hui qui prendrait
le risque de semer des ogm se trouverait
condamné et l'état à travers
l'administration l'obligerait à détruire
sa culture
donc ça dans l'illégalité ils seraient
dans l'illégalité puisqu'il ya une
interdiction de semer des 9e ce
territoire le problème qu'on a c'est
qu'on continue à importer pour
l'alimentation du bétail du maïs ou du
soja transgénique qui est lui encore
malheureusement autorisé comme y'a pas
d'étiquetage sur les produits animaux et
bien aujourd'hui les citoyens ne savent
pas si la viande les produits laitiers
ou les oeufs qu'il consomme ont été
produits avec des animaux nourris avec
des ogm ou pas et donc là c'est encore
un combat et j'espère que au niveau des
ministères de la santé de
l'environnement l'agriculture on va
mettre en place cet étiquetage alors
pourtant il ya eu un avis de la part de
l'agencé européenne de sécurité
alimentaire ces experts ont conclu que
le monsanto 810 810 pardon ne présentait
pas de risque pour la santé pour
l'environnement qui a raison
l'ex a donc cette agence a repris une
nouvelle fois son argumentaire classique
à savoir que depuis qu'on parle des ogm
en 1996 pas une seule fois
cette agence n'a donné un avis négatif
sur à nos chers mais pas une seule fois
et pour une raison très simple c'est que
cette agence est complètement inféodées
à l'agroalimentaire à l'agrobusiness
on a vu un conflit d'intérêt la
présidence de cette agence a été obligé
de démissionner elles étaient embauchés
immédiatement par le lobby
l'agro-industrie et tous les experts
liés aux ogm sont des gens qui sont en
lien avec les firmes multinationales et
je dirais même plus loin c'est encore
plus grave
les éléments qui servent à analyser les
demandes ogm viennent des compagnies de
monsanto lui même donc on est dans une
situation où il faut remettre
complètement à plat
cette agence est aujourd'hui pour moi
elle est complètement discrédité et son
avis n'a pas aujourd'hui force de loi
alors vous avez des paroles très dures
assure à l'égard de cette agence est ce
que c'est
ces arguments sont sont partagé cet avis
est partagé par vos collègues ici au
parlement européen alors leur étiquette
bien sûr et c'est cela qui s'est passé
pour la première fois il y a dix jours à
bruxelles
nous avons refusé de valider les comptes
de cette agence la en plénière une
majorité de députés ont dit il n'est pas
question en raison des conflits
d'intérêts qui existe dans cette agence
il faut remettre tout ça à plat
là je crois que c'est quelque chose de
nouveau aujourd'hui à une prise de
conscience ici dans ce parlement pour
dire on ne peut pas accepter que les
agences soient corrompus par les
conflits d'intérêts et que ce soit les
firmes qui fassent la pluie et le beau
temps quand on a 500 millions de
consommateurs en face alors ce dossier
là va être
à la table au menu si je puis dire des
ministres de l'environnement le 11 juin
prochain
quelle va être la position de la france
et du nouveau du nouveau gouvernement
dont qu'elles participent
europe ecologie ce qui aura des
inflexions sur ce dossier ce que vous en
attendez alors je pense que la france
depuis 2008 à une position qui est très
clair qui est de ne pas accepter de
renationalisation du débat il faut
qu'ils me législation européenne devient
vite c'est à dire le vote au parlement
européen d'un texte voilà d'un texte
européen et la décision de la france de
mettre en place le moratoire depuis les
ministres de l'environnement qui se sont
succédé on est toujours eu des positions
très claires pour dire pas on n'accepte
pas aujourd'hui de faire des concessions
de quelque manière que ce soit tant
qu'on n'a pas une nouvelle façon
d'évaluer tant qu'on n'a pas la
transparence sur les agences or jusqu'à
présent la commission européenne n'a pas
répondu aux exigences de la majorité des
ministres de l'environnement donc ça
c'est la position française ce soir même
je rencontre la ministre l'environnement
et le ministre de l'agriculture je vais
en discuter bien évidemment avec eux
mais je crois que là-dessus la france va
toujours être une position très ferme
face à la commission qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire concrètement pour mieux
réglementer la la mise en culture de ces
organismes génétiquement modifiés
qu'est ce que vous vous prenez je pense
que l'évaluation qui doit en être fait
doit être fait à la fois du point de vue
scientifique reconnue de la santé mais
aussi du point de vue environnemental et
je dirais aussi socio économique parce
qu'on ne prend jamais en compte les
pertes de marchés lié au fait qu'on a
une culture qu'ils soient contaminés
on n'a jamais vérifier quel était
l'intérêt par rapport économique de
cultiver des ogm ou pas de gm
donc tout ça ça doit rentrer dans
l'analyse globale et nous ce qu'on
demande c'est qu'ils aient une expertise
globale pas simplement celle qui est
faite par l'efsa avec les documents de
monsanto
merci beaucoup josé bové d'être venu
sur le plateau d' europe hebdo pour
évoquer ce sujet très sensible c'est la
fin de cette émission on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires